the biggest thing is to just not be
afraid to try not be afraid of failure
and I think that that kind of mentality
is is really important to kind of
celebrate your wins but not get totally
distraught when something doesn't work
out the way that you planned Koda the
class II is an organization I started to
help girls have access to computer
science education we have summer camps
where we teach girls to learn how to
code over the course of two weeks they
build apps and really get a
comprehensive understanding of what code
is and how to build just about any idea
we're working on building out year-round
curriculum and teacher trainings and
really expanding the work that we do
growing up I loved science but I never
had computer science coding engineering
classes and it wasn't until I went years
later to go take a bootcamp
and learn basics and how to code and I
really realized how valuable that
skillset is even just that understanding
of how technology works is super
valuable and that's why I think it's so
important for you know girls boys
everyone to have access to this learning
earlier because it really can just open
up the way that you can problem solve
using this technical framework of
thinking I've always been an
entrepreneur at heart I love the idea of
starting a business that's always been a
dream of mine
long before modeling the beauty of the
world we live in today and the power of
code is that you can actually take an
idea doesn't matter who you are or what
kind of formal education you have and
build it out yourself
or understand what is possible to build
then that's why it doesn't matter that
I'm a model there's opportunity for
anyone to be an entrepreneur I always
grew up in a family and in a community
that the idea of giving back is not
something you do once you've made it
it's something you do no matter how much
you have or don't have and it's just
what you do and growing up in a house in
the mid
you show love by feeding people so for
me I've always loved to cook and bake
for others and I started a charity
project called Carly's cookies to donate
school lunches to kids through selling
vegan cookies totally crazy idea but it
combined all my passions and it was a
way that I could actually make a
meaningful impact by doing what I love
and I think that that is when your most
successful and fulfilled when you tick
both those boxes when you do what you
love and lead from that place first and
foremost and whatever you're trying to
accomplish I think that comes naturally
when it's from a place of just passion
because you have to work long days and
long nights and if you're not enjoying
what you're doing then it's probably not
a recipe for success
[Music]